tenemos una escalera de 10 pies
recargada sobre la pared pero se
encuentra sobre una superficie resbaloso
por lo cual empieza a deslizarse hacia
afuera y justo en este momento que
estamos viendo la escalera la base de la
escalera se encuentra a 8 pies de la
base de la pared y está resbalándose
hacia afuera a 4 pies por segundo
suponemos que la parte superior de la
escalera se mantiene en contacto todo el
tiempo con la pared mientras latvala
hacia abajo y aquí vemos la flecha
indicando que resbala hacia abajo y la
pregunta que se plantea aquí es qué tan
rápido está cayendo la escalera en ese
momento consideremos primero entonces
que conocemos y que no conocemos
conocemos la distancia de la base de la
pared a la base de la escalera ya me
molesta a distancia x así es que x es
igual a 8 pies y también conocemos la
razón a la que cambia esa distancia con
respecto al tiempo de x en dt así que de
x en de t es igual a 4 pies por segundo
llamémosle a la distancia entre la punta
de la escalera y la base de la pared ya
me molesta a distancia h lo que se nos
pide en este problema es entonces de h
en de t dado que conocemos esta
información encontremos entonces una
expresión que relacione x con h para
poder derivar entonces con respecto al
tiempo aplicando la regla de la cadena
para encontrar de hdt sabiendo toda esta
información bien sabemos que xy h se
relaciona en todo el tiempo a través del
teorema de pitágoras suponemos que aquí
tenemos un ángulo recto
así es que x cuadrada más h cuadrada es
igual a el cuadrado de la longitud de la
escalera que es igual a 7 y lo que nos
interesa es la razón a la que esto
cambia con respecto al tiempo es decir
vamos a tomar la derivada con respecto
al tiempo a ambos lados de esta igualdad
necesitamos aquí entonces algo de
derivación implícita tomamos entonces la
derivada con respecto a t
es cuadrada la cual es derivada de x
cuadra con respecto a x2 x por la
derivada de x con respecto al tiempo de
x en dt y aquí estamos usando la regla
de la cadena veámoslo la derivada de x
cuadrada con respecto a x2 x x de x en
de t
estamos aplicando la regla de la cadena
para llevar x cuadrada con respecto a t
de manera análoga la derivada con
respecto a tdh cuadrada va a ser igual 2
h que la derivada de h cuadrada con
respecto a h por la derivada de h con
respecto a t
'estamos aplicado en la regla de la
cadena veámoslo de nuevo esto es la
derivada de h cuadrada con respecto a
che es 2 h por la derivada de h con
respecto a t estamos derivando h
cuadrada con respecto al tiempo que
tenemos del lado derecho
bueno la longitud de nuestra escalera no
va a cambiar con respecto al tiempo por
lo cual es 0 la derivada de una
constante y ya la tenemos una relación
entre la razón de cambio de h con
respecto al tiempo
razón de cambio de x con respecto al
tiempo cuando conocemos en un momento
dado el valor de x y el valor de h y
aunque no conocemos el valor de h lo
podemos encontrar cuando x es igual a 8
pies usando el teorema de pitágoras así
es que aquí tenemos que 8 al cuadrado
más h al cuadrado es igual a 78 al
cuadrado es igual a 64 y restando 64
ambos lados obtenemos que h cuadrada es
igual a 36 obtenemos entonces que h es
igual a 6 tiene que ser el valor
positivo porque el valor negativo no
había sentido aplicaría que la escalera
cayera más abajo del piso por lo cual h
es igual a 6 y esto es algo que de
alguna manera ya estaba dado por el
problema podemos regresar entonces a la
ecuación que obtuvimos aquí conocemos el
valor de x nos fue dado es de 8 pies
conocemos la tasa a la que cambia x con
respecto al tiempo que es 4 pies por
segundo acabamos de calcular h que es
igual a 6 y podemos entonces despejar
para encontrar la tasa a la que cambia h
con respecto al tiempo hagamos eso
tenemos entonces que es 2
8 pies por la tasa de cambio h con
respecto al tiempo que es 4 pies por
segundo cambia a razón de 4 pies por
segundo esto hace 2 por 8 por 4 + + 2
por el valor de h que es 6 la altura en
esos momentos es 6 por la tasa a la que
cambia h con respecto a t y todo esto va
a ser igual a cero tenemos entonces que
2 por 8 por 4 va a ser igual a 64 más 2
por 6 12 de h dt esto es igual a 0
restando 64 ambos lados tenemos que 12 x
de hdt va a ser igual a menos 64 menos
64 dividiendo entre 12 ambos lados
tenemos que de hdt vamos a ponerlo por
acá de h en d te va a ser igual a menos
64 sobre 12 de hdt es igual a menos 64
doceavos simplificamos esto y esto nos
va a dar a menos 16 tercios
y esto es igual a
de cambiar un poco a la derecha es igual
a menos 52 un tercio pies por segundo y
hemos terminado chequeamos nada más si
ese sentido este signo menos con la
realidad
bueno aquí nuestra escalera está cayendo
la distancia al piso se está cortando es
decir si hace sentido ese signo menos en
la tasa de cambio con respecto al tiempo
hemos terminado